good morning john today oren was
bouncing on
the couch and he was singing the abc
song he has a lot of energy these days
it's very good and
as per usual when he got to h i j k he
sang
h i k j element o p and this has been
going on since he learned the alphabet
song
like almost two years ago now but this
time i looked at him and i was like
that's a little kid now
like eventually he's gonna have to learn
the alphabet in the correct order like
he has the whole rest of the thing right
and then i was like well does he because
it's not like there's a good reason it's
in alphabetical order so if he says kj
instead of jk who care except then i was
like actually no
it's arbitrary there's no reason why
it's that way
but there is a reason why it's a way
porn's gonna have to at some point
uh be able to look things up in
alphabetical order and this isn't
something that i'm worried about when he
was
two he used to always say when referring
to himself he would call himself you
like you have to go to the bathroom or
you are thirsty and i'm like
i get what you mean and it makes sense
right we call him you
and he's up here being like okay so i'm
you and i'm like no
you are you
like for a two-year-old whose whole
world is very new
the following sentence isn't very easy
to parse no you're you
no you're me when you're talking about
you you're me but eventually without us
even noticing it like one day
he was just saying i instead of you so
like there's nothing i'm worried about
he's gonna get j and k right eventually
but this whole
thing made me think about another thing
as it so often does
which is that just because something is
arbitrary
doesn't mean it isn't useful and i think
that we get those things
mixed up a lot whether something has a
reason for being the way it is
has no impact on whether or not it's
useful
in fact there are lots of things that
have great reasons for being the way
that they are
but that's actually not useful like the
keyboard
there's there's a reason why it's laid
out this way it's just not
a good reason anymore so mechanical
typewriters didn't get jammed like
we don't need to worry about that it's
full of electrons but once it was that
way
we're not gonna change this is permanent
now it maintains its utility because i
need to be able to sit down at a
different computer and still be able to
type the biggest example of this of
course
is language none of these words need
to be the words that they are like
there's no reason that the sound
protein bar needs to be like that's just
a weird noise like okay yes it's a bar
and it's got protein in it but both of
those words
that was a bad example ear ear
doesn't need to be called an ear but
everybody needs to call it the same
thing
that has tremendous utility as we see
when we go to places
where people speak different languages
now this is usually the point in the
vlogbrothers video
when i would tie this interesting little
thing that i had a thought about into
something
that's relevant to your life or maybe
even to like
the the world as it exists right now i
thought hank was just being silly and
making noises and then he really tied it
in
to like robin hood and gamestop stocks
maybe i'm too stressed out
i haven't been sleeping great i've got
you know just thinking about
stuff that needs to get fixed in one way
or another and so i kind of got nothing
like i got a couple of things but it
would have been way too
hard to get deep into how i feel like
this impacts
us on a deeper human societal level so i
just gave up is that the point of the
video
sometimes you can get halfway through
something and be like uh
well this is good enough i don't need to
wrap it up in a nice pretty bow
i'm just here in your youtube
subscription box to say
that just cause something's arbitrary
doesn't mean it's useless
that's it we exist in a stew of
completely
made-up things that don't exist for any
particular reason
there was no system applied to their
creation and yet they remain
dramatically useful to con to the
continued existence of ourselves and our
society
i'll see you on tuesday